[Musik]
schön dass alle seien herzlich
willkommen
sonst hab spaß
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja das war unser gartenfest und dieses
fest wäre nie zustande gekommen wenn wir
keine hilfe gehabt hätten hilfe
natürlich auch von vielen ehrenamtlichen
helfern
ihr habt euch wirklich alle ganz spontan
gemeldet das war wirklich eine woche vor
veranstaltungsbeginn und herzlichen dank
an euch alle dadurch auch ein ganz
großes dankeschön an die sponsoren alle
sponsoren gelder gehen komplett an die
stiftung und ein ganz großes dankeschön
an alle besucher ich habe mich wirklich
über jeden einzelnen gefreut kommt mich
mit euch unterhalten eure kinder
schminken werden fotos zusammen gemacht
und ich glaube dass das erste große
projekt richtig toll wird wir werden
nämlich mit dem stiftungsgeld eine
kindergarten küche bauen
der kindergarten ist in über 50 jahre
alt hat nur eine ganz alte küche da
können die kinder wirklich nicht so
wirklich viel drin machen das werden wir
zu ermöglichen durch eure hilfe
und wir werden natürlich noch ganz viele
weitere projekte machen da könnt ihr
einfach mal unter diesem link
nachschauen
da gibt es dann immer weitere infos
vielleicht habt ihr auch eine idee was
wir als nächstes machen könnten
und ich freue mich schon aufs nächste
mal für uns war es das erste garten um
sommerfest eine messe ist da doch schon
ein bisschen was anderes und ich habe
mich echt mega gefreut euch
kennenzulernen mit euch zeit zu
verbringen und ich hoffe wir können so
was in zukunft noch öfter veranstalten
danke für eure hilfe
bis zum nächsten mal